because going back to like being able to
work in a coffee shop don't like
i find it so hard to just work by myself
in my room sometimes like i just like
the feeling i get distracted
by yourself yeah yeah i get distracted
by my own thoughts sometimes yeah i
don't know sometimes i just like having
an atmosphere where just it's just
people doing stuff and people doing [ __ ]
which is why like i i love working in
the office now when there's people yeah
because like i like that too because
we're all working though yeah
exactly yeah but when we're at the
coffee shop i feel like
you know i'm i'm kind of it's it's like
that one guy who won't stop talking
about transformers at the party i feel
like i've just brought something to an
area where
what kind of parties are you going to
write
i feel like i i'm intruding on the
atmosphere of the location even though i
know i don't give a [ __ ] when someone is
working at a starbucks but i feel like
i'm i'm doing something weird when i'm
working at a starbucks well i've i've
always been that person that like even
like during school i could never study
on my own i had to study with other
people otherwise i just wouldn't focus i
used to be but then i swapped i don't
know why really yeah i like flip-flop
between the two i can do either but if i
do one for too long then i just i need i
need i need like sometimes you got to
change up your routine right because if
you did like a full day of studying with
your friends you only really did like
three hours of studying
yeah but that's like three hours more
than doing it on my own yeah but so i
feel like i do 12 hours with my friends
where six of it uh hey have you seen
this funny youtube video oh yeah and
then three hours has actually started oh
yeah yeah yeah when i do it on my own
it's like four hours of solid studio see
i i can't do that okay because like even
like even when i'm at home in my office
and i'm like okay i have to get [ __ ]
done i can't just sit down and work for
three hours straight it depends how how
severe the stuff is i need to get done i
never i never find myself in that
situation when the stuff i need to get
done is like i it needs to get done
today i'll get it done today oh yeah of
course if it's something but if it's
like oh you know this video is coming
out like a deadline's not coming up
it'll be it'll be pleasant
yeah i just think there is just too many
distractions on my work computer
unfortunately yeah laptop doesn't have
those distractions no because okay when
when
it's like it's like exercising at home
versus exercising at the gym right
because in theory i don't know about
that no no no no i think it is because
like in theory in theory if you exercise
at home it's a lot more efficient right
if you just buy a home gym you can just
exercise at home you can [ __ ] buy wii
fit you should you should like lose
weight losing weight speed one but like
when you go to the gym everyone around
you is there for a purpose or is just
doing something something you want an
office
[Music]
it sounds like you want to go to an
office well like yeah well that's why
you still working coffee shop now or is
it here only um i i still work at coffee
shops okay sometimes so i don't i don't
think that that that comparison is
comparable like because you know a gym
your home has
more of the correct equipment that you
need to work you have the cameras you
have the mics you have
as a youtube you have everything that
you would need for a desktop you have
the ergonomics your starbucks doesn't
have the yoga yes and you know i've seen
some of the stuff sometimes they're busy
man you can't get the ideal chair you've
got to sit on those shitty stools
not if you go first thing in the morning
that's that's the way that's where
you're going right you can't just watch
so i could get and clock in before
everyone else like
honestly
i'd like that's this is how you know
i've like worked in a coffee shop like i
know i know the peak optimal time to go
to starbucks to get the seat that i want
and the seat that i want is like right
in the corner it's got it's got a out
power outlet as well so you can just
work there all day um and it's just
perfect you have enough of an atmosphere
where you don't get distracted by the
people around you but it's but you still
get the nice i can just imagine god
lining up first thing in the morning 6
a.m this guy must really want to call
him everyone everyone else on the
business shoots with their macbooks
waiting
honestly you can't go during lunch time
or any time past 4 p.m here because then
it's just too much too many people but
any time outside of that you get free
choices i've never been to the starbucks
yeah and it hasn't been busy as far as
like if if your job for example if the
kind of content you did didn't always
require a camera right or you know
sometimes a lot of the videos you do
is just pure research right when you're
researching things to buy and you know
stuff like that i feel like you can do
that kind of work in a coffee shop and
have a change of an environment but i
could also do that at home but that
you could do that
what i'm arguing is that you know if you
need something to be more productive i
feel like a change in environment really
does [ __ ] help i get so frustrated
because you know i'm using the laptop
and i'm like [ __ ] i wish i had my
keyboard i wish i had my mouse you know
like i start getting frustrated that's
not as fast as how it is right i'm like
i can do it way faster at home
see i'm like
to me to me i've i've i i get what you
mean but then some because i'm too used
to working at home sometimes like the
smallest thing can just distract me it's
just like if it's not like perfectly
optimized or perfectly optimally
if something's not optimal then it would
just like distract me i also don't want
to wear a mask when i'm working
yeah i just want to be home this day and
age it's a little more of a pain in the
arm yeah i just oh man you know i just
don't want to work with them like on a
laptop for like a few hours with my mask
on i'm like go home and work yeah
exactly and breathe
my air vents
sneeze
and you know also going back to the gym
comparison you know again as i was gonna
say like the gym has all the equipment
you'd want your home is never gonna be
as stacked as the gym unless you have
like a private gym in your house even
then right like you won't get the you
won't get the cringy playlist you know
all of these things add you know either
water machine cringey playlist cringy
playlist yeah you know the the justin
bieber baby that comes on occasionally
what starbucks are you going to no
oh the gym yeah i enjoy the the pitbull
that comes on repeat
yeah they would like they would play the
same songs i loved it i don't know why
but also you know you get you uh there's
just so much more at the gym there's so
many more facilities and you're and the
coffee shop doesn't have any facilities
you're downgrading whereas the gym
you're you know the argument to go to a
gym is that you can unequivocally get an
upgrade in equipment and you also get
the environment um so i think that
comparison falls short sadly on change
my mind well the thing is right because
i feel like atmosphere is important and
it's not all about equipment
if if if equipment was all that mattered
especially when it's working then
everyone would need [ __ ] three
screens and a gamer pc to make videos to
make youtube videos
but that's not the case
as somebody who used to make his videos
on uh 300 laptop i can tell you i need
the pc yeah i i need it i
12-hour render times i find a mistake
[ __ ] no man i can't do that
i'm not saying you need to you can do
everything in the coffee shop but i'm
saying if you need a changing
environment get out your house sometimes
touch some grass i swear to god it would
help it'll help your productivity it'll
help it'll help bottom line are you
telling me are you telling me that that
apex logo in the corner doesn't [ __ ]
taunt you i don't know every time you
have like five minutes and you're just
like
maybe i could play again sometimes
do you think you can play apex in
starbucks uh no you can't you can't
somehow that would be true power
privilege